that was great great work so I really
nice okay I'm sorry sorry if that was
bad really
maybe I'm risking too much I get like
that all the time
I was spit I felt this nervous since I
first tried stand oh now is everything
okay my ex-boyfriend he's havin this
gallery opening and I promised I'd go
wow that's cool that looks pretty you
want to go with me I really don't want
to go with myself
oh yeah sure why not what should I wear
oh it's LA I can just go like this
there's a new app called Suzy and
actually count how many times in chewing
it it will you tell me if I say
something stupid and I just I feel a
little out of place
yeah that's not really my scene either
there yes please Jeff just don't leave
me alone okay oh okay yeah sure I I will
not leave you alone
summer hey thank you so much for coming
I wouldn't miss it
you look great who's your friend
this is Jeff we work together hey Jeff
hey so what do you think it's yeah it's
really nice really nice okay I mean
she's cold so so yeah she wears it wolf
it's not really what I was going for
Oh what it's really about is Fibonacci
being organic you order something on
Amazon and then their data mining you
they're pressing your buttons they may
paper
let's consume lies consume maybe beep
muskan - it's fine I could roll with it
once I'm
sensitive let's go get something to eat
Jeff no cuz it's summer and can we just
talk for a second talk about alone you
mind why don't you guys need a drink
I'll be fine
let's have you back pal yeah okay sorry
you have a problem buddy oh yes sure
sorry oh just be over here I have a
Moscow Mule in a copper mug or in just a
house Rhett